Tanya steel editor-in-chief of
epicurious.com I've actually was born in
London but I moved here when I was six
years old moved to New York City and
it's been a very interesting influence
in my life England because I've spent
every summer of my life from the age of
0 to about 21 years old where I would go
back every summer and I grew up in a
very Anglo households in New York City
so I'm very much fifty percent kind of
English in fifty percent New Yorker and
has created kind of an interesting
interesting bubble of and meld of
influences and cultures I think that
growing up in New York in the 70s and
80s which is when I was really here it
was a great time to be in New York New
York was very different at that time and
it had a real grittiness and an edge to
it that it no longer has and so I took a
lot of that kind of more raw part of New
York City I went to clubs all the time
when I was a kid I went to max's kansas
city and CBGB's in studio 54 and the guy
i ended up marrying actually worked at
xenon which was a big disco at the time
so I grew up in a very interesting time
in New York and in some ways I'm kind of
sad that New York no longer exists like
that kind of the taxi driver that you
see in New you know New York scene of
the taxi driver but in many ways I think
that I still retained a very Englishness
and part of that is being very polite
and solicitous it may be overly so and
my kids in fact are very polite and I
have two identical twin boys and they
are probably the most polite kids I've
ever met